all right
god why internet why i know thank you
zack that's how i felt about it
yeah oh we were doing so good i can't
understand it
we streamed all week and that [ __ ]
didn't happen
now i'm gonna have to like [ __ ] hulk
out again yeah
wait why is it so much brighter in here
now
i don't know some weird [ __ ] isn't it
where's that light coming from i don't
know it's really weird because i feel
like the last time
it's like really dark and now it's like
really light and i can't see
yeah i can't see where the light's
coming from okay we're here so go ahead
but we're
yeah maybe someone doesn't i called you
bro i think you
well i thought you did i don't know if i
beat it
it's in your mind okay he's gaslighting
me
i didn't say i didn't call you bro
she said i called her bro it sounded
like pregnant maybe it wasn't
all right so um so let's talk about
um young and freud and let's talk about
the differences between the two
now here's one thing i was telling tom
because i thought he would
appreciate this little anecdote this was
something that
i read in a biography of young
and this was one of the one of the
things that uh
kind of highlighted the fundamental
difference between the two of them which
led to one of their
which led to their rift later on
so they kind of came from the same
um framework i guess because young was
about 20 years younger than freud
young was kind of seen as
freud kind of saw him as his successor
he even called him like the crown prince
like he was gonna be the guy that was
gonna
you know carry on that particular
theory into the future i think
at least according to one biography that
i read i think one consideration that
freud had
was that you have to understand that in
the context of the time period
a lot of psychiatrists a lot of
psychologists and stuff like
that were jewish and i think that freud
was afraid
that psychiatry psychology was going to
be seen as like a
jewish discipline so i think he was very
excited that someone like carl young who
was not jewish
was going to be carrying on the mantle
so it didn't look like
a particularly jewish kind of [ __ ] um
so that might have been a consideration
also
but the thing about it they both kind of
came at things
from a similar point of view in the
sense that
you had you know the conscious mind
you had the subconscious or unconscious
mind
which in freud's point of view
had all of your bad [ __ ] like all of
your repressed memories that was causing
all of your [ __ ] up like neuroses and
[ __ ] like that later on
you had all that going on and then you
know freud also had something called the
id which
you know young had sort of a thing that
was kind of like that too like an
archetype called the shadow
that was kind of similar but one thing
that young had
that freud did not have and this was one
point of contention between the two of
them
was that young thought that underneath
your conscious mind which is obviously
all
the [ __ ] that you're conscious of your
personality you know your
your ongoing sense of yourself as an
individual then you had your
subconscious or your unconscious which
was
not necessarily bad [ __ ] but just all
the kind of stuff that you weren't like
aware of memories that were repressed or
[ __ ] that was going on underneath the
surface that you weren't necessarily
aware of
young thought that there was something
else
underpinning that which he called the
collective unconscious now he
kind of and this again was a big place
where he differed with freud freud did
not have anything like this
young thought that there was a well
essentially
of um i guess you call it like
species specific memories or species
specific
symbolism that all humans
could access i suppose
you know what i'm saying kind of like a
combination between heaven and hell
because yeah and one thing that he kind
of and i
and i'm not like totally averse to this
idea
um he he was kind of coming at it from
the point of view
where look they've accepted evolution as
true at this point
and they're kind of like well everything
else evolves like our physical forms
evolve and everything so our brains must
have evolved as well which obviously
they did
so he's like so we must have some kind
of like species specific
not even species specific because it
goes back to before we were even humans
there must be something imprinted in the
brains
of all that you kind of inherit from
ancestors whether they were human
ancestors or even going back before
like before humans and as
evidence of that he pointed out to the
similarities because he was
as i said he was very into mythology he
was very into studying like comparative
religion all that kind of stuff
so he's like look you see similar
um symbols and similar stories and
similar it's like
coming up in vastly disparate
cultures so there must be something
underpinning that that everyone is kind
of plugging into
kind of like that thing out of altered
states yeah amber altered states well i
kind of feel like
that's yeah that's where they got this
that's where they're got that
well and like i said jungian theory is
so
ingrained i feel like in particularly in
mysticism in like artistic kind of
you know mindsets people with artistic
mindsets i kind of feel like it's so
ingrained that you might not even
realize that it comes from one
particular person
you know what i'm saying just because
his ideas have so permeated
throughout the culture at large
but as i said it's not a crazy theory
because
we did evolve we did evolve from you
know
other species were all interconnected
so it's not crazy to think that we might
have some kind of
well of particular symbology
imagery that we're all drawing from and
that
and that causes us to have the same kind
of emotional reactions to them
you know what i mean so that's kind of
where he was coming from he's kind of
saying like you know you have your
conscious mind on the top then you've
got your subconscious mind which is your
personal
unconscious that's your own [ __ ] that's
repressed memories or whatever but what
he didn't
see that as necessarily negative which i
think freud did
and that was again another point of
contention
but then he went a step further and said
no there is an actual like a
a species or a racial kind of thing like
underpinning all of it when everyone
we're all kind of drawing from the same
wellspring because we've all evolved
from the same
thing mark says we evolved from pookies
we did yeah
[Laughter]
well see this is why i talk to pookie
like a person because it's all from
pookies
me and pokey are very you know we have
very similar dna
she is like a tiny person she just can't
really talk
she kind of talks but like you know not
in human words a pookie is not a
non-human
it is a type of human they just don't
have the ability to [ __ ]
actually explain things
but she's pretty good at getting her
feelings across
and getting her point across right it's
all [ __ ] visual
i mean she doesn't seem to have that
hard of a time letting us know what she
wants
right i mean she seems pretty uh astute
in that so being evolved from pookies is
isn't necessarily a bad thing i am
totally
i would not be offended by that at all
that's what we see that's one thing that
always kind of bothered me about people
that were because i used to be
like way back in the day i was like
really fascinated by creationists and
like what the [ __ ] problem was
and it seemed to me that they got really
offended
by being a we evolved from
age even though that's not technically
correct
yeah um you know we have a you know
obviously we have a common ancestor with
apes we didn't evolve from apes in the
sense that because
obviously their apes are still around
but it's you know it's a branching thing
obviously
but it seemed to me that that was
something that was
that was making them not want to believe
it because they were
offended but it's like oh you're saying
that i came from a monkey
right like they seemed like they were
really [ __ ] pookies too
i'm like one monkeys are awesome so shut
up
and two i don't understand why that's
offensive to you and
it's like no one's saying that you can't
be
a monkey so basically you might as well
just throw your poop at people nobody is
saying that right
clearly because the monkeys were like
what
hey i'd be more offended if i was a
monkey
that humans offended for you know would
you evolve
by the monkey what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] why are monkeys are not offensive
no
and actually we've been watching videos
of those gorillas like in that zoo or
whatever
they're very human and they're always
honestly
they're they actually they act just like
people so i don't
understand why anybody yeah they'd be
like that
the [ __ ] that they do is like you can
tell what's going on in their minds
because they're acting just like a
[ __ ] human act
their facial expressions their body
language everything
i don't understand why anyone would find
that that's unusual about them it's not
offensive at all
it's right within human parameters
they're like and they're and they're
delightful creatures
why is anyone offended by that i don't
really know right i'd be offended if i
was a monkey
to be compared to a person to be honest
with you
[Laughter]
but yeah i didn't get that so so yeah
like i said so i don't think that's
like totally weird i know there might
not be a lot of like scientific evidence
to back it up
but you could see where young was coming
from
where he's saying look it's all across
the world we have these really common
symbols um and a lot of common stories
and a lot of things that come up in
people's mythology and stuff like that
that are really really similar to one
another even though
ostensibly these cultures did not
interact
so there must be something ingrained in
the human
brain that is making that manifest
you know what i'm saying so it's like
that's not that crazy thing
so he kind of like went a lot farther
than ford did than freud did because i
feel like freud
um you know and i'm not [ __ ] on
freud i know it's you know cool to [ __ ]
on freud or whatever but it's like
he did kind of have i feel like freud's
um outlook was a lot
narrower as i said freud was very
he didn't have a lot of patience for any
kind of mystical stuff he didn't have a
lot of patience for any paranormal stuff
which like i said i get that because i
you know don't either generally but
in in that sense i feel like he went a
little too narrow
in his outlook because he as i mentioned
earlier
said pretty much everything that's the
matter with you and as i said this is a
simplification
everything that's the matter with you
can generally be
tied back to some trauma that you
experienced as a child and it was
generally probably a
sexual trauma or something to do with
your genitalia whether it was like
toilet training or
as i said maybe your mom looked at your
junk funny or something like that
and that caused all your problems all we
have to do is identify
what that was and then we can fix it
that was another thing too because i
feel like freud
their kind of thrust was to
identify the basis
of people's neuroses so that they could
fix them i feel like young
was less focused on fixing stuff
as he was identifying
commonalities in people's
experiences and using that
to come to a better understanding of
one's
personal um identity
you know what i'm saying because he came
out with you know he came up with the
whole thing later
which was he had you know the theory of
archetypes obviously which is not
i feel like it's that's kind of like
portrayed as
i feel like that gets portrayed a lot as
like [ __ ] tarot card kind of [ __ ]
like you know like
the [ __ ] which i guess that's kind of
accurate but that's not
really that's not really what it was
it's just kind of like
these kind of parts of your psyche
that i don't know it's like it's really
really hard for me to explain but it's
kind of like parts of your psyche that
what you're trying to do is reach what
he called individuation
which is kind of you're getting to a
balance between
your conscious self your subconscious
self
and the collective unconscious you're
kind of getting to this point where
everything is in balance with one
another
so i feel like that was kind of his goal
not so much fixing what was wrong with
you
but maintaining a balance of you
your identity you know in compared to
everyone else's identity and like your
relationship with the world
you know what i mean maybe i'm like
interpreting
wrong but that's kind of how i'm seeing
it i never really was [ __ ] hip
with [ __ ] these [ __ ] 19th century
guys
and the way that they saw things i
always thought the
with the way these guys approached stuff
was was a little bit too systematic
you know what i mean yeah you can see
what they were yeah that was like a big
thing back then we want to like break
everything
yeah and break things down into some
kind of system and i never really
reality isn't really like that but
they were trying to invent a science if
you ask me
yeah you know they're they're they're
writing books
so they're gonna invent a science on the
back of writing a book
and uh they're gonna try to make some
kind of a method
that's the way i always saw well they
were trying to distill
the complication right of human
existence which is very complicated
down to a system that
you know if something was bothering you
you know you could do a b
and c right and then you would get to a
and i don't
that's not always gonna work yeah that's
not the way life is
um nowadays it would be some dude on the
internet
trying to come up with a meme to explain
it that's the way it would be today
um it might be some kind of meme lord
you know what i mean um doesn't
necessarily mean that they were wrong it
just means that they
that well they only captured like a
portion of it yeah
yeah they're trying to give it to you in
the [ __ ] eight
in the 1800s sense of it of the word you
know what i mean
that's the only way i can relate and as
i said i feel like
i feel like it's very human to want to
find
systematic or very simple solutions to
things which like i said it's i'm not
[ __ ] on people that's just a very
human thing to want to do
because you know you like to think look
i have
this problem and i want to be able to do
x y z to solve it
um but that's not always how [ __ ] works
out yeah i always saw
i always saw what these guys did as
trying to make a science sure that's
that's the way i uh
which as i said you i mean you have to
there wasn't anything like this prior to
that
yeah and as i said i do feel like
aspects
of even freudian eve and jungian
analysis has been of value to people
in the modern age so you can't say you
know i'm not saying that it fixes
everyone's problems obviously
but if it's helped people
then it has contributed something of
value
it's just that i'm always really leery
of anybody that says that they've come
up with a system
to solve any [ __ ] problem that you
have but
you know as i said so i do agree with
young that he thought freud's [ __ ] was
like too reductive he's like look
you tie every every problem back to
someone's like sexual
traumas from their childhood um
everything
is negative like all the [ __ ]
um because basically freud's thing
about the subconscious or the
unconscious was that that was all like
your repressed memories
and in that sense they were repressed
because they were too unpleasant for you
to deal with so it was all like negative
[ __ ]
now young was like he was a lot more
open-minded than that he's like look
that's too negative it's like you know
my
unconscious or you know theory of the
unconscious mind it's not
yes there's repressed memories in there
but it's not all negative it's just
anything is in there it's like [ __ ] you
don't remember like [ __ ] there's
all kind of stuff in there it doesn't
necessarily
mean that it's repressed because it was
too horrible for you to deal with or
you know it nothing like that and also
another difference was that freud kind
of thought that
well your childhood was responsible for
everything that happened to you going
forward like into your adulthood there
was always something
that could be tied back to some like
[ __ ] that happened to you in childhood
young thought that was like i said a
little narrow
and he's like look what about people's
future aspirations
what about that kind of so he kind of
thought
he kind of had like a more well-rounded
view i guess because he's just like look
everything isn't about your past
everything isn't about past trauma
everything that you do
doesn't necessarily have to do with some
bad [ __ ] that happened when you were a
kid
um you know what about what your dreams
are what about what your aspirations are
was it you know that can
influence your personality as well so he
was kind of a lot more open in that
regard
now another thing that young did too
he was um because we kind of got into
this a little bit as well
because i know you probably wanted to
talk about this too because of the
poltergeist thing
um young was a big advocate of
um you know he believed in paranormal
activity but he kind of had the same
view of it that you have
in the sense that he believed that
poltergeist activity existed but he
thought that it was a manifestation
or an exteriorization which was a word
that he used exactly
of someone's mental turmoil now
i was telling him about um
a an anecdote where he and his wife
like young and his wife were in vienna
visiting
freud and they were kind of having a
little bit of an argument
about paranormal activity because freud
was like a super super he was an atheist
and he was like a super super skeptic
about
any kind of paranormal activity he
thought it was all [ __ ]
young was not so much he didn't think it
was supernatural as in the sense that he
didn't think it was ghosts but he
thought that it was
you know it some kind of exteriorization
of
people's mental states so they're having
an argument like in a library or study
or something
and then while they're having the
argument
this really big banging noise like comes
out of the bookshelf
right and young says that's exactly what
i'm talking about we're having an
argument about this [ __ ] right now
we're getting upset about it and that's
an exteriorization
of how upset we're getting about this
[ __ ] issue
and freud did not buy it he's like
whatever [ __ ] that it was just like some
kind of like
you know it was it was a coincidence it
was a random noise
and then allegedly young said
um yeah well i'll prove it to you it's
gonna do it again
in a minute and apparently it did so
that was another kind of this was right
around
maybe a year or so before they had their
final falling out where they didn't
really talk to each other anymore
because there were some pretty
fundamental differences in
their world views that i guess it got to
a point they worked together
they were in you know um
it's weird too because i feel like there
was some kind of
a few uh biographies have said they
never
um the two of them never like obviously
had sex with each other or anything
wait what but there was some kind of
like freud even said
in a letter to someone else that he had
like some kind of quote unquote like
wild homosexual feelings toward
young and young kind of said that he had
a crush on freud too so i
kind of feel like there was a little bit
of a sexual tension going on there i
don't
they didn't have sex with each other or
anything like that but there was some
kind of like sexual tension going on
with that
and i should note too that young was a
big advocate of
everyone being bisexual because of the
whole anima animus thing which he came
about later on wait well anime animus
anima animus oh you didn't know about
that okay
so one of the things that he came up
with one of his archetypal things
yeah um anima is the female impulse
which is in every
man and animus is the male impulse which
is in every woman
he believed that every person no matter
what their gender
um had the opposite gender like that
energy
saying everybody's bi yeah i mean
basically that's essentially what he was
saying and and he's saying that the
problem is
that people are taught to suppress the
other side of them
yeah well well like women are like talk
oh don't be masculine and like
men are taught like don't be feminine
but he's like that's really
keeping people from reaching their full
potential
as people because you're shutting off
like a large aspect of your personality
when you do that
um so that was kind of like a big thing
that he was talking about so i don't
think it's that weird
that him and freud were kind of like
like i said
nobody said they had sex with each other
because like i said um
you know young was a he was a huge
[ __ ] poonhound but um
it's not that strange to think that they
had this stunt cut because they were
both
very similar personalities and
they had a lot of the same ideas but
they were also
kind of a little bit in rivalry with one
another so i do kind of feel like there
was like some weird sexual tension going
on there
and as i said they did kind of like
admit it
at least freud did um so
that's not really that strange to me but
i think that might have contributed one
of these
sounds like some 1800s [ __ ] to me
actually well the weird thing about it
is that you have to think too
that in the 19th century it was much
yeah it it's weird to think about now
we made a big deal out of nothing else
here's the thing too
is that i think people think that you
know gender roles were very rigid back
then but i think to some
extent no i don't think they were no to
some extent
in the victorian era yeah
men were a lot more effusive with their
emotions
towards their male friends and in some
ways
i mean from everything from all the
literature that i've read from that time
period because like i said i'm super
into like victorian
fiction and [ __ ] like that i do kind of
feel like
it was almost more acceptable to be more
emotionally open with your male friends
than it was with your like
say your wife there's a lot of [ __ ]
victorian stuff
to to me as metrosexual as [ __ ] okay
they were also doing weird stuff like
raising little boys as girls
did you know that well no they
well they i mean they were kind of like
[ __ ]
not really raising [ __ ] young boys as
girls they were kind of like
uh asexual yeah they didn't really
see i mean
if you see pictures of little boys
from that time period dressed as girls
well yeah they just had little
little dresses on yeah everybody wore
those yeah
they didn't really see that as girly or
boyish necessarily that was just
something that babies wore
i wouldn't listen to them dudes back
then man i'm just saying
well it goes back to what we were saying
before about they were [ __ ] weird
dudes just being like fainting at the
lesson like i you know sometimes i read
like victorian stories
because like a lot of them are dudes and
you know because dudes wrote them and
dudes were like the main characters and
stuff even if women wrote them like
dudes are the main characters
and the dudes back then were like
massive drama queens it's like people
talk about nowadays but like the dudes
back then it's like they could not
[ __ ]
they just couldn't deal with that and
they they passed out
yeah dudes that era were not [ __ ]
physically they weren't very physically
fit they didn't [ __ ] work well it
wasn't a thing
it wasn't a thing and they were just
like
come on you know what i mean it wasn't a
thing
about it well it's just interesting
because i feel like people these boys
were [ __ ] solely
they were so i do like i said i feel
like people they were so
[ __ ] i feel like people have a
misperception that in the victorian era
the genders were very rigidly no it
wasn't really i didn't have that
it wasn't really like that it wasn't
really like that
and a lot of the stuff that you think
about as masculine nowadays
was not considered masculine or was not
seen in that way back then you can go
back to the world
wars in the [ __ ] 30s and 40s
when [ __ ] were killing each
other with [ __ ] wild abandon
okay and if you looked at those [ __ ]
soldiers
of that era they were little skinny guys
they weren't very big you know what i
mean you didn't see
guys starting to come about into this
whole physical fitness and being [ __ ]
macho
and [ __ ] until the 70s
and that was only some of them yeah i
mean that's a pretty recent invention
yeah
yeah that's very recent that would be
uh you know [ __ ] the original
bodybuilders out on [ __ ] venice beach
in california in the 70s
[ __ ] arnold and [ __ ] all of his
buddies and that was only
[ __ ] a very small few
that were into that there are more
here's something that [ __ ] a lot of
guys aren't understanding
during the golden age of bodybuilding
back in the 70s all right
where guys were first starting to get
really big
that was a tiny amount of men in terms
of the [ __ ] earth's population
there are more guys now working out and
getting huge
than their than ever ever
yeah ever you know
so i just think it's funny well i always
think it's funny too because like i said
the this is a thing like everybody talks
about i was like oh dudes nowadays such
[ __ ]
it's like look dude have you read
victorian fiction because
seriously the kind of guys they got
right now on [ __ ] youtube
getting big and working out in the whole
fitness thing and [ __ ]
guys [ __ ] with their own home gyms
and taking all these weird [ __ ]
anabolic anabolic [ __ ] compounds
that's all
new yeah that's very that's
a pretty new thing and there are bigger
dudes
now than ever and there are more of them
than ever
yeah yeah well in
you know [ __ ] even [ __ ] like nowadays
people think of like pink and blue
like that's like girls and boys uh
up until the early 20th century pink was
considered a boy's color
because it was it's like red red and red
was considered a masculine color
so blue was considered that was like for
girls so
this this [ __ ] it's not it you know it's
it's not something that is
you know static and everybody like oh we
we're
all like decided on what's masculine and
feminine like
throughout time or whatever like that
it's not really like that that's it's
very very
[ __ ] fluid but yeah so
so the two of them even though what
sanders in there talking talking talking
about me and wins
on wednesday saying being k in the
middle of pandemic you can't do that
that's when i was messing with what's
his name knock it off sandra
why is being gained the pandemic any
different than no no no
i said something wrong zach i was saying
that look at zach trying to be gay in
the middle of a pandemic
that's what i said back then we're
trying to be like actively gay right
yeah he's trying to stay
in the [ __ ] middle of got a whole
[ __ ] pandemic going on he got zach
trying to be gay in it
and she's talking about that i can't
understand
where there's a will there's a way yeah
that's all i'm gonna say
yeah it's all fine
so so yeah so um these two dudes
as as much as they were buddies and they
loved each other
um yeah there was like a big rift coming
they
like i said freud was too much
of a rationalist perhaps
young was more into he had a little bit
more of a mysticism thing going on so
there was that kind of thing
young thought that freud was too
narrow in his outlook and that seemed to
piss freud off
uh freud admitted later that he's like
you know nobody likes to be deposed
nobody likes
you know to think that somebody else is
gonna like take their place or whatever
so there was like some egos
um you know happening too so there was
there
that whole kind of thing that happened
um where they didn't really want to look
at each other's
ideas now uh the rift was kind of like
they kind of like saw each other for a
little while but it wasn't really like
definitive until 1912 because young
published psychology the unconscious and
that was basically the last straw like
freud wrote some letters being like man
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i
thought you know i'm paraphrasing um you
know that's
that's the end of it i'm not like into
it anymore
so basically what ended up happening
then 1913 about a year after that book
was published young
kind of um he started having
some some people would call it some
mental
issues he called it a confrontation with
the unconscious he started hearing
voices
he started seeing visions um
he started to worry that maybe he was
developing
schizophrenia or that he was getting
some kind of psychosis or something like
that
but what he did i mean to his credit
he was kind of freaked out by the whole
[ __ ] but
being a psychologist he was kind of like
maybe
i should just kind of
unplug and study this stuff as
objectively as possible
so even though all of this stuff was
very upsetting to him
he decided that he was going to
start recording everything that he felt
everything that he saw
and he thought that that would be a
really valuable
tool for you know whatever going forward
so he decided too that he was going to
start
inducing hallucinations as i said
i don't know if he was doing any kind of
hallucinogenic drugs or anything like
that
but he was definitely trying to
he was definitely trying to encourage
seeing hallucinations because he thought
that that would give him insight
into his own psyche and that that would
be
valuable for other people going forward
um
as much as he was afraid of it as much
as he thought that it was like a
frightening experience
he was going to lean into it so what he
started doing
was he had these little journals that um
were called they're called the black
books even though a couple of them are
brown but you know whatever um he
started writing down
every dream that he had every you know
daydream that he had every hallucination
any kind of weird [ __ ] that happened to
him he started writing it down
and um so he had a whole bunch of those
i think there ended up being like seven
of those which he called black books and
then he started transcribing them into
what would later become uh called the
red book
which was like this big leather-bound
book he called it libra novus
you know which is latin for a new book
obviously
um and he started writing down
everything in there this was just some
[ __ ] where
since he was going through a shitty time
in his life and you have to think too
that this was around the time period
that world war one broke out which
um by all accounts was very traumatic
for him
also um he ended up actually he did
actually serve in world war one he got
drafted uh
into the army he was like being but he
was in switzerland so
they were neutral so what they would do
is that they had all these hospitals set
up but like
soldiers from either side if they were
kind of trying to get out or they were
coming through switzerland
they would put them in the hospital and
like they were just neutral so they'd
just be like we don't care if you're
like a bad guy a good guy
we're just gonna fix you and do whatever
we need to do
so that's kind of what he was doing but
apparently he had like a
world war one was not a fun time for him
and he was having a lot of
existential crisis and whatnot so he was
having all these hallucinations and
whatnot but like i said
he decided that he was gonna write it
all down because he thought that it
would be
valuable for other people down the line
you know what i'm saying
so as i said he's since he wrote all
this stuff down we talked about the red
book earlier
um he kind of spent
16 years off and on like writing in it
and painting in it
you know doing drawings and all the
stuff and
it uh when it was done he kind of just
stuck in a drawer
and he didn't really give any
instructions to his family as to what
should happen to it after he died
so there was like a lot of argument
about it they did actually end up
publishing it in 2009
it's actually quite beautiful if you
want to take a look at it
as i said it looks like an illustrated
manuscript um
because he wrote all this stuff like
really really small like all the [ __ ]
about like
his journey into the interior
this of his psyche i guess like all the
[ __ ] that he came up with that
you know he goes off on this thing it
almost sounded like it was like a
homeric
epic yeah like the [ __ ] that he did like
in this book it's like he went off on
this
there's like [ __ ] deserts and
mountains and i and i killed this
beautiful youth and i did this that and
the other thing you know what i mean so
it's just like this
it's this epic journey but it all
happens like inside his mind kind of
yeah and it was like kind of portrayed
as some kind of [ __ ]
wild almost like you know i mean like
some kind of a [ __ ] wild spiritual
paranormal [ __ ] book that if you got
your if you've got your hands on it
that it might actually kind of you know
cause you to
have paranormal experiences which i
guess
i mean it may if you have certain uh
proclivities
i mean as i said it was basically just
his diary entries about
his dreams uh the visions that he was
having and he didn't
censor it so he just basically talked
about like you know
last night i had a dream of this and the
other or today i had a you know vision
that i was you know going across the
desert and there are all these dead
people
like coming at us so he just wrote
things down without
really worrying about if other people
read it or not
especially paranormal well
as i said he did have a big thing about
i think that's probably why his legacy
has endured
because he did really have this weird
it's almost kind of like a timothy leary
type of thing
i want to say because he even though as
far as i know he wasn't super into
psychedelics or anything but he kind of
occupies that same space in the culture
where it's kind of like we're going on
an
internal journey yeah the timothy leary
angle
[ __ ] really like uh kind of like
touches home with me yeah it's it was
like a timothy leary that's kind of what
i
got from him and and timothy leary of
his age before his time
sure because you're you're going inward
right you know you're you're going on an
internal journey
and hopefully what you come up with
while you're in there
is instructive for people outside
to some fashion which i think is kind of
what he was shooting for
because as i said he really did believe
that everyone had just these
common symbologies
that would reoccur in people's dreams
and stuff which is why dream
interpretation is such a massive part of
jungian analysis even to this day
because there are still jungian
analysts out there now um and that's
kind of one of the first things they ask
you they
kind of um they ask you to keep start
keeping a dream journal
because they think that [ __ ] that
happens you're they're like look even
[ __ ] that happens in your dream that
seems bad like everything seems like a
nightmare
that's not necessarily it's not
necessarily bad
they just have this whole really
complicated
system of coming up with
what that dream might mean to you
personally
right so which as i said i'm you know
i'm not sure because
sometimes i think that the dreams you
have aren't necessarily
i think freud kind of had more of a
he kind of had more of a point of view
that dreams were
wish fulfillment to some extent
um which i don't know if that's the case
because sometimes i think dreams are
just [ __ ]
random yeah imagery imagery that certain
things happen in my dreams that's not a
wish
it's more like a nightmare yeah that
don't necessarily mean anything
so i do kind of feel like and i'm not
saying that the you know
what people dream about doesn't mean
anything because obviously it's coming
from your brain so it must have some
significance
but i think young was maybe on a better
track with that because he does kind of
feel like look it's not necessarily wish
fulfillment but
you know the [ __ ] that you dream about
that might be
uh some kind of symbolic it might be
important to something that you're
thinking about right now it doesn't
necessarily mean it's bad that just
means that
this is what's occupying your mind at
the moment and it might be coming across
in this particularly symbolic sort of
way it's funny because like looking at
this stuff
now there's not as much
to it by today's standards as there was
i remember it back in the day and it was
like [ __ ]
it was bizarre but compared to what we
got going on now
in terms of you know what i mean
computer technology
and [ __ ] understanding of [ __ ] the
human mind
and science it is very dated
what you're talking about now it's very
dated
i mean it's cool but it's just
it didn't really it doesn't really
[ __ ] carry over into our age
as much as it as it did
yeah well and like i said i think some
threads of it are still
relevant because you have to think that
young did come up
with [ __ ] that is probably still
relevant nowadays he was the one that
came up with the
inherent dichotomy between people that
are you know the extroversion and
introversion
um he did kind of establish
the foundation that some people's
personalities are more outward based
like they get energy from interacting
from other people
outside of themselves whereas some
people get more energy from
or recharge by going back into
themselves
so those are two fundamental differences
of personality which i think is still
kind of relevant um he did come up with
that
which was which act actually ended up
being the basis of the whole like
myers-briggs
personality type thing with like the 16
personality types which a lot of people
know nowadays you can take [ __ ] all
kind of tests on the internet people are
still like yapping about it nowadays
um you know where you have like that
kind of whole extroversion introversion
like thought feeling intuition
that kind of stuff that's all from
jungian thought
all of that and um even though
as i said you know maybe you could call
that a little bit of [ __ ]
but you know it does have some value i
think
um i've taken those myers-briggs tests
i'm an intj um if you
wondered
i just remember i just remember thinking
about this kind of stuff in the 90s
and back in the 90s it seemed more
relevant
back then than it does now
you know what i mean i suppose yeah it
just does
yeah seems like it hasn't aged as well
as i remember
but he was the one too that came up with
uh you know kind of the archetypes
yeah um which i feel like that's pretty
relevant in fiction still
um and you could talk about joseph
campbell in this
uh context also where you have
i mean and like i said archetypes from a
jungian point of view are not
necessarily like an image like oh the
hero or the mother or anything like that
he was just kind of talking about
ways that you're i guess i'm not really
sure how i want to put it but ways that
your psyche
or parts of your psyche would present
themselves it's not necessarily like an
image or anything like that
but it was some
you know it was just a way of kind of
putting into context
some aspect of your psyche so you had
you know stuff
like uh you know archetypal
archetypal images like the mother the
hero
um you know things like that that
everyone across cultures would recognize
um and that recurred throughout
history and recurred throughout cultures
you also had
um things that were like a complex
which usually i kind of feel like that
scene is negative but
he was like not necessarily it was just
that whatever there was more
stuff attached to in your
mind like you had more things attached
to this particular idea than any other
idea that meant that you had a complex
about it it didn't necessarily mean that
it was bad
but